yeah maybe actually should close a
little earlier continuing overdue Doctor
Who review and we arrived at closing
time I honestly wasn't sure what I was
gonna think about this one my general
impression of it has never been glowing
but I also see it frequently derided as
like really really bad and a lot of the
things that people seem to take issue
with the way the Cybermen are used and
the way they're ultimately kind of
defeated I didn't have an issue with it
I didn't remember having an issue with
again didn't love it but I'm like I
don't see where the problem is now if
you think I'm leading into kind of how I
started with let's kill Hitler which is
I get it now that's not quite where I'm
going the thing the way the Cybermen are
you specifically
I still stand behind I still think it's
fine it's not amazing but it's fine that
said a lot of other stuff I found myself
thingy I don't remember that being this
grating cuz there's uh yeah there's a
bit of that going on so it's the return
of Craig and the doctor just shows up at
his house and because you know he's
doing his little farewell tour and Craig
now has a kid Alfie or Stormageddon and
I do like I like that it's not a
particularly clever joke the idea that
the baby sees himself as some sort of
conqueror and he knows mom and not mum
and yeah that that's not a super clever
joke but I kind of like it it kind of
works I think part of it is Matt Smith
being the one to say it I don't know if
the whole I speak baby gag which didn't
orig
in this episode to be fair but I don't
think that whole thing would have worked
as well with any doctor other than Smith
it just you just kind of makes it work
so that I'm fine with but you know in
the way that the lodger managed to take
a scenario that should have felt grading
and cringy and make something that I
felt was fairly entertaining out of it
this time around
it feels grading and cringy and I think
a big part of the problem is all of the
initial discovery and the initial how
are these two gonna interact with each
other is gone so and I think that sort
of uncertainty particularly on the part
of Craig was a fairly sizable part of
why that dynamic worked in the lodger
whereas here we just jump right in and
we get the jokes right off the bat and
at least for my taste and what I tend to
find funny the jokes aren't very good
there I don't like the misunderstanding
jokes you know people misinterpreting
the idea of partner or companion and
start thinking that the doctrine Craig
are together like
oh isn't that crazy two guys who aren't
into each other that way and people
think they do that's hilarious
like let me be clear I'm not offended by
that at least not in the sense of lgbtq+
representation or anything like that I'm
slightly intellectually offended because
that is just such a lame entire joke at
this point so you know yeah I I don't I
don't much care for that and the the
just the dynamic between Craig and the
doctor I think maybe it's because Craig
is completely on the doctors side this
time he's not questioning him a ton he's
not doubting him he's and you know him
doing that across the lodger and then at
the end trusting him was a great you
know way to end and
climax that story here him just trust
him right off the bat like the whole
dynamics a bit dull but boring there
isn't really a lot to this thing I do
like the moment where the doctor spots
Amy and we see the poster in the
modeling and the sent for petrichor I
actually quite like that and again like
the idea that Amy would get into
modeling to me that tracks that kind of
fits who she is that that would be the
sort of things she'd pursue that makes
sense to me it feels grounded in
character so that works I think it's
kind of a sweet moment I like that the
doctor doesn't approach her he just sort
of has a little huh moment for himself
um so then there's the Cybermen and I've
seen over the years some people get
really upset about you know that the
Cybermen are thrown away on this jokey
episode I think the way the Cybermen are
you see er is actually more interesting
than a lot of the ways we've seen them
used and I tend to feel the same way
about the Daleks in both cases I think
by and large there are exceptions but
generally speaking they are at their
least interesting when they just show up
as an army when they just show up on
mass and they're this huge threat we
have to deal with that is incredibly
uninteresting I find them much more
interesting when they're on the backfoot
when they are behaving a bit different
from what we would expect where
something seems a little off because
that adds a sense of ooh not entirely
sure what's going on here even though I
know these villains and now that doesn't
always pan out because that it that sort
of thing that I just mentioned is true
of say Daleks and Manhattan and
evolution of the Daleks and it was true
of victory of the Daleks none of those
quite worked but I still feel that that
initial scenario of the Daleks doing
something other than just showing up
with a fleet is more interesting
execution can still be botched but with
the Cybermen and this I don't really
think it is I think the idea that
they're you know trying to get power to
get their stuff up and running again
they're kind of converting a few people
one at a time they've got the cyber mats
out there some of us are always a weird
thing to me I kind of like that they had
the little bitey thing to it cuz I think
one of the fundamental problem of the
cyber mats if you go back and see their
various appearances it I haven't seen
all of them to be fair but the
appearances I have seen of the cyber
mats in classic who they never really
did a particularly good job of
explaining why these things were
dangerous or making them feel dangerous
or sometimes even really probably
explaining what it was they were
supposedly doing they just kind of show
up and just sort of okay whatever and
like they gave us something a little bit
more visceral to be and like a little
bit freaked out because it's this metal
thing but those look like very organic
teeth and like that's actually kind of a
cool little scare moment too so I like
what they did with the cyber rats I
thought that was neat and the resolution
at the end well I will grant that it is
kind of cheesy the fact that Craig
basically defeats the Cybermen with love
is that cheesy and a little bit sappy
and ridiculous well yeah but it's also
got precedent because these the Cybermen
of New Era doctor who especially have
been pretty well established that
emotion is a big issue for them I mean
you can go back to when they were first
introduced back in series to the way
they were defeated was to shot off their
emotional HIPPA torso all their feelings
came back and that basically killed them
and so the idea of emotion in general
and particularly strong emotions in
affecting the Cybermen in a negative way
that's a established premise so the idea
of it basically undoing a fresh
conversion that just happened and they
haven't really had the opportunity to
fully take him apart yet they just did
the first step of supposedly shutting
off his emotions so that they can then
do the rest the idea of a strong enough
emotional bond with his son you know the
the protective father instinct kind of
being enough to fight
man yes it's kind of cheesy but I also
buy it it makes sense to me given what
we know and what we've seen from the way
Cybermen have been done in modern era
Doctor Who so I don't have an issue with
that my issue is just with with the
humor just cuz the jokes are cringy and
painful and oftentimes obvious and
frequently dragged out I mean the the
issue it's an issue of writing and of
pacing in terms of the I'd say the
editing in the direction because the
jokes are delivered by Matt Smith and
James Corden about as well as they could
be they're just not great jokes and they
get lingered on for way longer than
they're worth and also a little bit like
night terrors I feel like there's a
missed opportunity to draw a more direct
parallel to rather significant recent
events the fact that the doctor is
interacting with a baby you know kind of
like how it felt like a missed
opportunity and night terrors it feels a
little bit here like off off the back of
you know a good man goes to war this
should feel more meaningful than it does
because like it just the nature of the
doctor trying to in some way protect a
family and a baby again should feel like
it matters given recent events but it
just kind of doesn't and that's not
necessarily a flaw and the abstract is
just like why would you not take the
opportunity to do that I don't know so
that's closing time yeah I was gonna say
it's not as good as I remember I don't
remember being great but that I ate I
feel like I just had kind of willfully
forgotten most of the stuff that now I'm
watching again I go well that didn't
work and what it's stuck in my head was
the stuff that did work but it's it's
okay I don't find it frustrating or
inferior I just kind of find it kind of
dull
so that's closing time you watched it
lately what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it
you can really help me out by clicking
the like to subscribe if you haven't
already and supporting me on patreon if
you would wish to do so it is immensely
helpful but there's other stuff for you
to do as well I've got merch I've got
links to social media stuff it's all in
the description click on it or don't you
don't have to because end of the day
you're the council I'm just finding the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]